nadi let's talk about the awards we
haven't really talked about them before
and there were three very important
awards this year yes indeed um the first
award the individual ftth award was
awarded to hardwick tauba
whom you know
he is the former director general of the
fdth council europe and before that he
was also the first president of the fdth
council europe
which means that he has been around for
quite a while and uh has really uh he
gained the he obtained the award because
he is such a strong defender of fdth
and has contributed to uh
growing the organization to what it is
today
and we had the first for the first time
two
operator
ftth awards um the first one post
luxembourg who they are the incumbent
operator in this country
for deploying fiber they actually have
50 coverage of the population which is
very impressive for an incumbent
operator
and the second operator uh not in level
because they were both equal
in in the prize is india
india is a
an operator from poland
and they have deployed fiber
in the greater poland region which is
suburban and rural uh
suburban and rural area
which is great because we know that
fiber has a very high impact
and contributes to bridging the digital
divide
so we were very pleased and we were even
more pleased because actually poland did
really well in the market panorama yes
and they've entered the rankings for the
first time along with a couple of other
countries exactly so yes this is another
announcement
poland
germany
and croatia
all three countries entered the ftth
ranking for the first time
so this means they now join the what we
call you know the lead leading economies
in ftgh terms the thing is though of
course when you enter the ranking it
means that you have just one percent
penetration which means that one percent
of the households are ftth or fttb
subscribers so it's it's a good sign
it's going in the right direction
there's still work to be done but uh
it's it's nice to welcome some new
countries in the ranking anyway
talking of countries i think you've had
a record number here this week indeed
yes um in the previous few years we had
uh 86 85 87 different nationalities
represented as delegates in this event
and this year i was quite surprised i
just got the figures just before coming
for this interview we have 96
nationalities represented uh which is
quite amazing uh we are we almost have
people from all over the world really
coming to this event uh which is
and remains the largest ftth focused
event in the world
fantastic now one of the highlights i
know for you was the opening plenary uh
today 1500 people and more possibly but
tell us why it was a highlight uh it was
a highlight for me personally because i
had this dream of having uh you know
this entire plenary uh holding a sign
showing their you know wish to get fiber
and in fact i managed to have a thousand
five hundred people in the plenary
holding this sign
it was really great we had a
photographer on stage take a
magnificent picture of all these signs
it's really impressive so i'm very happy
that's great well we all want fiber and
i think the figures are showing that
more of us are getting fiber which is
great news so thanks for talking to us
thank you very much brian